John Merrow see Fox Sports and MLB
Network joining us on the phone John it
used to be John Palmer OSI then I think
for a time was JP Morosi and now it's
just John Merrow see what's going on
well Dan first of all good morning
second of all I I answer to any of those
names and probably a few less laudatory
names that I've been given over the past
as well so any of them between friends
that you and I go way back as so any of
those that that strike you in the moment
is good with me
so John / JP / John Paul was in my
audition group when Fox Sports one was
launching in a six seven years ago and
John I don't know if you remember that
but that was a that was remember very
well that was an interesting group we
had our first conversation there in the
the avocado room on the Fox lot that's
about you're right about six or seven
years ago now goodness it was a while
ago but that you were outstanding then
and even better now my friend uh you you
are you were amazing for saying that in
our audition group by the way Brockman
it was it was miles Simon it was John
and it was Petros Papadakis I didn't
know I'm from these coasts so I was the
petrol some money radio show with Matt
money Smith love Petros have worked with
him a couple of times now but in that
particular audition group I was the host
we had three guys that gave you a couple
of topics you know how it works those
tease it up the guys answer a couple of
questions they passed the baton well
Petros not really one for passing the
baton now it was like a runaway
locomotive in my ear the producer who I
didn't know at the time you're I am Dean
I'm I'm trying to get a job right and he
said not much you can do now was the
same thing going through your head at
the time John it was a little bit and
now I I had the good fortune of knowing
Petros through radio connections
previous that I had been on his show so
I I was prepared you you electro said a
few things that he would always like to
keep at the back of his mind
biographical things that he always likes
to bring up whatever what
on the air so I was I was ready and I
was prepared for my good friend Petros
but great I remember he was still I
think he kept saying recalling I believe
a little bit Jim Nantz is called when
when Arizona won the championship Simon
Says championship he kept saying that if
you recall that to my house during the
course of the audition which is which is
of course after they won the NCAA
champions good moment but I'll never
forget Petro state assignment says
championship you kept repeating it
during the course of the day was it was
pretty good yeah that was a fun time and
they were they were rolling us through
there like like cattle when they were
launching fs1 all right let's talk a
little baseball John Merrow see from Fox
Sports Emily network on the line with us
now let's not bury the lede John I'm a
huge Nationals fan so I had a feeling
that Anthony Rendon was gonna go
somewhere else it really bum me out I
know he wasn't into the deferred money
the Nationals were offering but seven
years 245 million dollars the identical
contract that Stephen Strasburg by the
way got with the Nationals sans the
deferred money ending up with the angels
how does this change things for the
angels and out Wes well then it changes
things from the perspective of the team
getting a badly-needed victory on this
this free agent market and and I think
really really restoring some of their
relevancy for the market there in
Southern California after the Dodgers of
course won six consecutive seven
consecutive now National League West
Championships and the Angels actually
have the worst record in the AL West
over the last four years so from a
standpoint of emotion and momentum the
Angels needed a day like the one they
had yesterday however then they also
need starting pitching yeah and there's
a reason why they pursued Gerrit Cole
there's a reason why that pursued
Stephen Strasburg and that is that they
are coming off a year in which they
posted the worst rotation er a in the
American League and of course the
Anthony rundown as many things he is not
a pitcher so they have to find a way to
address that I do believe that they're
going to look to add multiple starting
pitchers still we have to address
catching as well probably the bullpen so
I love the move because of what it
represents and and now Mike Trout will
have
probably the most productive offensive
teammate he has ever had with the Angels
was certainly the Albert Bulls by the
time he came in he was beginning that
the second half of his career if you
will ren-dono is still in his prime and
I think the two of them ran down and
trouble be dynamic they're gonna have to
probably out score some teams to win but
certainly a good thing for the Angels
even though it cannot represent the last
big move of their offseason you talk
about those starters they had a 5.6 er a
last year and just 22 quality starts as
a team Gerrit Cole had more than that by
himself which is pretty incredible so
they lose out and the Gerrit Cole
sweepstakes just weren't willing to pay
the type of money it was gonna require
to sign him were they looking at Rendon
the whole time or they just pivot right
away once they lost out on Cole that's
an excellent question Dan I think they
were to an extent and obviously it was
not easy to stay in touch and have
contact with both Gerrit Cole and
Anthony Rendon and Stephen Strasburg for
that matter because they are represented
by the same person Scott Boras of
Newport Beach California so the fact
that all these meetings were present and
and the GM's and the owners in many
cases the club presidents were involved
they were getting constant updates on
the group and and team Boris
team Boris won the Winter Meetings that
was a tour de force from a negotiating
standpoint now well over a half a
billion dollars of contracts signed in a
span of three days I'll repeat that more
than a half billion dollars of contracts
for one agent in three days and of
course not all that far from where Scott
lives so a big home victory you could
say huh for Scott Boras his clientele
and oh by the way there are still some
more guys to sign hon Jin Ryu Nicolas
Castilla knows Dallas Keuchel there are
more clients of Scott Boras who are
still out there and available so a big
week and again I think that they were
generally the Angels what we're staying
in touch with Scott and getting progress
reports and updates on Ren don't but I
do believe that up until Tuesday their
focus was Gary Cole let me ask you this
I've been seeing this number 5% out
there for Boris and in the last four or
five days 878 million dollars when you
throw Moustakas in there five percent of
that is baseball different than than
football and the NBA in terms of what
agents get paid because I always thought
it was two to three percent for these
agents five percent Dan is what I
understand Scots Commission to be I of
course have never been a good enough
baseball player that I would have ever
found that out on my own by talking to
Scott about representing my my baseball
talent but I have heard it many times
that that'd in fact is what his
commission is 5% which as you point out
works out to more than 40 million
dollars for this week alone which is
pretty extraordinary sum of money so it
really is it's a good week for his first
Corporation for his brand last winter he
had to really do a creative job of
pushing Bryce Harper's free agency deep
into the new year and and of course
eventually signing with the Philadelphia
Phillies
but for these three players Cole's
Strasburg Rend own the market was much
clearer there were fewer evident flaws
in these players overall the the
appetite to spend was greater among MLB
teams at the moment there are more teams
that are that believed they're now
moving out of a rebuild and more into a
competitive phase we've seen that as you
mentioned with Moustakas signing with
the Reds he has money Grondahl going to
the white sox the Blue Jays are heavily
involved in trying to sign hon Jin Ryu
so teams that were not really big
factors in the market last winter are
there right now and very present so I
think Scott benefitted from having
candidly better players and a market
where there was a better willingness to
spend and Scott may have also made a bit
of an adjustment on his own right to see
where the market was and and and reading
things and realizing just how robust the
market was at this early stage and this
is a great week for baseball Dan there's
certainly last winter the weight was not
really good for anybody if it was it was
tiresome for fans I
the agents were frustrated the teams
were for a variety of reasons
restrained in their activity this is
much more like the days of yore and for
me as a young baseball reporter I still
remember hearing these great stories
about mm and a rod and Manny Ramirez and
Mike Hampton and this is now our our
generational week of one of the biggest
weeks ever in the history of offseason
acquisitions and it really damned to me
very poignant li sets the stage for the
next decade is about to begin at a
little more than two weeks is this the
the events of this week for the teams
that got these players and those who
missed on these players the coming 20 20
s will be defined in large part by what
happened this week in San Diego
if far different this year than last
year you know Kimbrel and Keuchel not
signed til June you talk about some of
the teams that didn't get the guys they
wanted you know here in LA
it's a Dodger town they were in on cold
they were in on Rendon it was a swing
and a Miss on both guys we know the
Dodgers they don't want to pay those
massive massive contracts heck the
Angels have three guys they have
contracts 200 million dollars plus the
Dodgers have never handed out a contract
like that but they're still missing a
piece where do the Dodgers go now well
they have to me Dan a couple different
aspects of their club that needs some
rejuvenation I think they need a big bat
that they were involved on some level
with Rend own but they need a big bat
for the lineup I believe and and also
someone who's going to be in the
everyday club that gives them energy and
that's where I love the idea for them of
trading for Nolan Arenado as much as
that may be a long shot at the moment I
think it would be a great concept
Francisco Lindor as well with Cleveland
because if they don't bring in someone
who has that positive personality energy
to go along with great talent the
defining story for them in spring
training will be why didn't you get it
done in October and why is October 2020
going to look differently than October
20 19 or 20 18 or 2017 when you weren't
good enough either to win the World
Series
and and that's going to be a difficult
mental hurdle for this team for the year
to come there has to be a different way
to go about things and I think it
involves bringing in someone like a
Francisco Lindor other players that
would have that presence about them
there's not that many in the game but
then I think it's paramount the Dodgers
must do that and certainly they also
have to look at their rotation as well
they're losing if they don't resign them
hunging ryu they're losing rich hill
who's out and a free agent right now so
that they have to find a way to replace
those innings and there's a reason why
they were pursuing Gerrit Cole they have
to find a way in my opinion to do add in
one credible starting pitcher and
optimally one difference making bat the
cost of that in a trade may well be
Gavin Lux but then I think right now
given the disappointment and you saw it
up close cover in that series they have
to find an answer for their fans
something positive to hold on to do you
give up a Gavin locks for say David
Price no I would not do that
Gavin looks to me has a chance to be a
multi time all-star really appealing
player I would I would trade Corey
Seager
before I created Gavin lux I would and
we'll see how that statement stands up
Anders the test of time in the coming
years but but I would if I'm the Dodgers
I would much rather give up Seager and
add in a Francisco Lindor
then I would give up a gavin lux
although the tricky part is Dan Lux for
Francisco Lindor
it would be a very tough move because
that's only two years of control right
it's all Renato or if it's a longer term
player under control for five six seven
years then I would give serious thought
to giving up Gavin lux in that
circumstance but for two years very
tough and that's why I think the
Cleveland Indians are really right now
having a high asking price
I wonder Dan if in the coming days as
the Indians look at all this time we now
have as one of the key things about the
free agent signing early is that it
gives these teams a lot of time to work
through trade scenarios and the Indians
have got Lindor and Corey Kluber
I think the Indians make at least one
big move and maybe even two here in the
weeks ahead
how does this
he bet situation play out I believed and
he's going to stay put in Boston he is
value as a player is so high his
contractual situation for the serious
salaries going to be astronomical it's
gonna be tough to move him for one year
and again it gets it gets back to the
way that team's view their own prospects
teams are very very reluctant to give up
premium level guys for one season rental
and we know Mookie is going to go into
the offseason next year and be a free
agent he is not going to sign an
extension with Boston or anybody else
for that matter so I think given the
high asking price of the Red Sox given
the prohibitive salary for many teams
that Mookie is going to earn this year I
think trade for me Dan is much more
likely in July if the Red Sox struggle
than it is right now simply based on
economics John Merrow see one of the
best in the business John thanks so much
for the time we really appreciate it I
know you've been busy a lot going on
it's you really put a bow on it and put
it into perspective for us a big couple
of days for baseball put you guys in the
headlines and it's been fun to watch
from afar thanks for the time my friend
yeah my pleasure great catching up again
it's been far too long and really
enjoyed the conversation my happy
holiday wishes to you and your family as
well indeed same here enjoy the holidays
that's John Merrow see Fox Sports and
MLB Network he is so good for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app